hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one shot now we're
waking up from the darkness I am still
here hello it happened again everything
just went really dark so dark the light
bulb doesn't even light it oh it's okay
to go it was gonna be ok don't worry
oopsy poopsy okay so we're we last left
off we made the bottle of acid and then
we cleaned off the robot whose actual
name is robot but I haven't talked to
the head engineer left so that must be I
would have given you coordinates but my
systems down so that must be silver who
well it's either silver or it's this
mysterious person that's still working
deep in the mines either way we got to
go over there so I'll be right back
maybe oh hi I thought you were dead
hello hello small person you're not but
bigger than I am welcome to the lookout
points Louis is the old quarry that
engineer lives a little more of the east
the entrance to the old mines is further
to the east I see thank you very much
for that
it's so weird considering you're up and
walking again so how far out did that
battery reach like that actually went a
long way silver are you the head
engineer excuse me again this I found a
robot who can take me towards the tower
but it's having some trouble so it told
me to talk to you alright what is the
issue it said something about its
navigation circuits being fried just the
navigation circuits apparently
markiplier and I fixed everything else I
think
I have something that may help robots
have the ability to trace material from
their source locations if you let the
robot borrow this that it's back up
tracking system should activate whoo
it's clover where are you saying those
clovers that the other bot was fly
aren't from here that's a very pretty
necklace what's made of amber found from
the Glen what's this thing inside the
amber the black clover that's the common
plant in our world it's also I'm not
sure if I can bear to part with this my
programming says yes but I still feel
conflicted never mind you need to finish
your mission more than I need to keep
sake here well thank you I don't know
what that means to that and this silver
the head engineer supposedly is quote
unquote tamed whatever that means but
she still has programming because
obviously she's a robot
but she's conflicted before I go is
there anything I can do in return
actually you know how to play chess yeah
well sort of I played it with some older
kids before then will you play a game
with me I mean I don't know the rules
very well but I guess it's the least I
could do
all right I'll give it a go I am a
complete amateur chess you're really
good at this
thank you I am a computer after all it
was built into my code ah oh what's it
like being a robot no I've talked to
other robots and they all say something
about programming code and stuff I don't
really understand it at all even you did
just now a little hard to understand
sometimes I know most of the robots here
are not tamed tamed watch out
there goes my Bishop taming is
complicated oh how complicated exactly
because my other bishop okay all right I
can't really explain what team robots
are but I'm one of them all the other
tamed robots have been moved to other
regions exactly where I don't know oh
there goes my little horse Knight right
Oh have you ever been to any of the
other regions I heard that there's two
more in the past yes I still have the
data the coordinates the memories I
don't know how much of that still holds
true the world may be a very different
place now because the Sun is gone no I
said this already didn't I the Sun
probably won't save the world the
decaying started back before the Sun
went out the sun's sudden death was just
the tipping point and things went south
really fast after that oh then there's
nothing I can do check watch why did
your Queen get there the only thing you
can do is complete your pilgrimage in a
way you are only supposed to be a second
chance for the people just like how the
Barons was only supposed to be a second
chance for me there's no guarantee that
things will work out but checkmate well
I'm bad at this
even markiplier the God couldn't help
you Niko alright
guess I've kept you long enough thank
you for listening I hope you get home
safely
well thank you also oh that's so sad
what is going on in this world that's
causing all these problems hello
off you go there's no reason for you to
linger in the Barrens I mean I imagine
I'm gonna come back if there's gonna be
I mean if someone's still in the mines
does that not mean anything there's no
vehicle with which to go down there is
there
I mean Silver's not accompanying me so I
got imaginin safety violation stranger
danger okay so I mean I have the amber
necklace so I'm assuming
yeah I'm assuming then I just go to the
rowboat and go on my way so I'll be back
I guess man sucks to leave this place
it's so sad here like why is it so sad I
mean I got to imagine that the the
dreariness and the night is falling the
farther away you get from the center or
maybe it's all this way and again what's
with these black corruption here the
black squares someone else was
mentioning is adding a note either way
I'll find out in just a bit
be back in a second okay buddy I think I
got what you need how about we do a
little bit of yeah there we go grab the
button hello oh this is amber from the
Glen I can remember now activating
tracking system setting course wait this
boat is over capacity you'll need to
leave behind some of your possessions oh
I don't think I'll be needing this
crowbar anymore
yes man gloves okay and dump them right
in the ocean yeah just litter all over
the place
see trip is gonna get caught in that
crowbar that is acceptable onwards we go
Louisville tea oh I'm so pretty he's
built into the boat oh what a little
goober Oh No Oh No
there's the Reach's are those the lake
lachrymose leeches hope you didn't need
anything Niko you're about to be torn
apart Oh what is this here's your stop
the Glen thank you it should be a
village to the north but that's all I
can recall that's good to know
farewell may omission be a success
are you leaving yes I must return to my
station but you'll be all alone again
it's okay I have not been tamed again I
don't know what that means everyone
keeps referring to that but I don't know
what that means
weird so what is the concept of being
tamed am I ever going to be able to go
back there I mean I explored every
looking cool ah
well I'm one step closer to the tower I
guess but this place doesn't look good
looks like a cemetery here oh it's
beautiful but kind of sad in a way I
mean other places sad too but yeah I
don't know there's all this I mean
there's another dock over there but
there was no other way to go with this I
mean this place is just filled with the
clovers which I was told is common oh
hey how's it going there the jar is full
of fireflies I'm catching fireflies for
mommy okay do you have a candle on your
header is that a feather I don't know
what's going on they're a little bizarre
was going on filled with small dried
fish where am I
hello there was a time when our people
used to live in these rooms I due to
flooding most of us have moved less
permanent settlements flooding all right
a land of GaN brittle Glenn used to be
in one piece you know but now it's just
a bunch of islands that gets smaller and
smaller ah
so the Barrens receded like the Barons
used to be an ocean that receded and now
it's what it is empty jar fishing-pole
jar of worms good it's a bed more like a
mattress so these people aren't robots I
think anyway hmm nothing's biting maybe
nothing's in there maybe there's nothing
left to any of this uh nobody they seem
to be having fun catching fireflies
but if fireflies are the only source of
light that they got left alula I don't
know Lula where did you grow
markiplier did you hear that dude yeah I
think it's coming from the southeast of
here but new dad we're a saloon oh how
do I get to the southeast you called for
a Lula is the best fishing spot I found
yet well the fish I can't hear longer
than my arm
maybe that's short arms Steve over there
stumpy arm Steve are you there
have you seen a Lula FG little girl he's
little bit shorter than you and wait
that's the son you are Savior yes yes I
am I talked to a god named mark Blair in
my head oh my stars sorry for my
rudeness huh
it's all right are you looking for
someone my little sister she's been gone
for three days now I've been looking all
over but but she looked like me with
smaller blue shorter long blue hair do
blue
okay I'm sorry I haven't seen anyone
like that was the last place you saw her
back in said the ruins she said she was
headed towards the tourists so I'm
waiting here now I ran out of places to
look all right then
good luck with that I'm gonna try to
find the ruins I don't even know where
that is I'm a new comment in these land
so I don't exactly got my bearings about
all this if you could point me to a
tourist centre maybe give me a map
send Dora the Explorer my way maybe I'll
get my way through here but until then
I'm lost
I just keep traveling down oh hello
robot hello person welcome to the
research station hello are you sent here
by dr. silverpoint Oh carry on then so I
need to find a doctor silver Ponte
whatever he said hello hi no I'm with
markiplier Oh carry on
hey you don't care about the God talks
to me in my head he's very loud and
yelling a lot hello
how come you're red instead of green
well more of a purple than red your eyes
and stuff a red I'm only here to pick up
this week's moth samples couple return
to my station in the city soon Oh so the
color-coordinated based on the places
that they are so the ones from here are
more of a green the ones back in Barrens
are more of a blue
so the land you come from I'm in charge
of collecting more samples cool you keep
that up man
congratulations hello person is the main
generator of the gladden market liar and
I actually fixed one of these earlier in
that place across the ocean this
generator does not need to be fixed
right now you take your markiplier how
do you say that get the fudge out of
here right you guys already have power
and all can I see how it works a
generator this one's got a working
battery and is that all generator needs
it's just a battery Wow can't believe
you is that simple all this time
phosphor trees and now being protected
under the new law please do not harvest
them I'm not I mean now I want to but I
mean I wasn't gonna phosphor tree
growths have been reduced as of late
that sounds bad
back in the Barents we just got to fish
up some for amp and then hope for the
best I guess
Oh water collection project a resuming
ok beep or hello living person hello I
have collected a duplicate water sample
would you like it
my programming says that organic beans
need water to survive so I shall offer
it to you oh thanks I'll take it
we'll take it hey as your god I could
use some water if you're gonna there
just got to be Hawking that around to
anybody a little glass tubes of water
water samples good for you man hey you
collect as much water as you feel like
it seems like this place might have an
axial way the monitoring anomaly what is
that thing an anomaly what are you
stupid organic being well yeah but
alright thanks for the beets
ok alright you carry on Nana I get it
I'm just an ignorant child talking to a
God inside my head I'm only carrying the
whole Sun in my arms feels like he might
treat me with a little bit more respect
than what you've been given me so maybe
you should
bring the attitude back out a little bit
they've won yell at him while he's right
there could hurt me could hurt me never
know with you guys all right so I don't
know where to go from here but the main
generate doesn't need anything but I
need to go find a doctor silverpoint
because apparently there's a reason to
come down here if I'm being sent for the
research station but I'm just not a
hundred percent sure where all that is
ooh hello ah some phosphorous rays have
been harvested down here don't they know
that new laws hello what a sample
collection in progress
all right you guys sure do love your
water I really appreciate you guys doing
all that that's good I guess don't know
what it means but then oh hey hey bigger
the Sun you're the Messiah are you on
your way to the tower mm-hmm you can
enter the refuge through this wall
you'll need to sign your name in this
good role first all right yeah Ben no
I've lost mine perhaps you should look
around the glen for another Oh
okay so I can't even progress until I
find a pen have you found something to
write with no I'm sorry I have not sorry
you're such a stickler for the rules did
I mention I'm carrying the son the
literal son and I'm talking to a God who
is probably capable of a lot of very
godly things hello person please do note
that the ruins below are partially
flooded Oh should we not be here there
is no immediate danger you organic flesh
back go down in there and drown to your
content ha ha ha I'm a robot using this
area as a dwelling is not recommended
however so please if you could run there
don't fall asleep or you'll die all
right thank you goodbye friend happy to
be mildly threatened by you what the
Frick is that a cluster of vines are
blocking the way
leet okay don't know what to do about
that this place sure is dank I'm not
sure what I'm supposed to be doing about
it other than look at the fact that it's
partially Flo oh hello I thought that
was a doorway oh this is a doorway oh
god not again
hello ah why is this the thing that's
happening
hello again Marga Blaire oh god it
changed my whole goddamn screen here it
seems I need to help you again Nico will
not be able to progress otherwise this
time the information you need is fall
into the most easily accessible place on
your machine do I see it it's behind the
game isn't it you'll know what to do
with it then will I all right so I'm
just gonna pop that debt oh that's uh
that's a symbol on my desktop that isn't
need what that is - boob with a dick as
far as I can see although my brain only
processes boobs and dicks Nico's you'll
understand when you reach godly status
such as me you really only see the world
in boobs and dicks not just black and
white man
not just black and white all right let's
carry on I don't know what to do with
that but at least I got it and now my
desktop is a lovely shade of that I
don't know if I'm supposed to remember
that for a pattern input anywhere what
have you I'm just gonna carry on with
the Sun in my hands and hopefully this
guy's messing with me cuz I mean that is
what's happening isn't it he's messing
with me these finds appeared mere
minutes ago weird really I've seen a lot
of them in doorways and stuff I just
assumed it was because this place is
abandoned a sign of distress are you
distressed child huh a living being is
in need of help but I cannot trace the
sauce ah is it me is that uh is that a
weird roundabout way to threaten me in
that I'm about to be in distress because
I'm down the sewers along with you I
don't know I don't know maybe I'm just
injecting my paranoia and anikó but I
think I think I've been playing one too
many horror games where there's threats
and death around every single corner
oh hang on let me talk to this guy first
hello person to children residing here
why why did you children reside near
here oh the pathway is blocked by this
tiny box Freddy marks him please please
come on tiny block Bob honey block Biff
beau oh no oh no these blocks they're
getting in my way
can these talk to where am I I just look
like a peaceful afterlife type saying
anybody want to kill huh now look sharp
they do however I got you Savior no I
don't think so I think I'm in the wrong
place
I think I'm gonna I'm gonna go I can't
believe it
you're real miss you are you all right
no we should get you to the village
maybe they could it's okay it's okay too
late for me but the Sun I haven't seen
it I haven't felt it in so long
save it if it's not too much trouble can
you lend me the Sun for a while I will
it make you better
no it will not save me I just want to
experience the Sun one more time for him
well Oh would it be too selfish of me to
ask III suppose not
I suppose not unless it's gonna turn
somehow evil on me but then again that's
my paranoia as a God that plays way too
many horror games what should i do
markiplier alright I got a bad feeling
about this just judging by all the vines
with all the thorns and you know I'm
thinking about poison ivy from Batman
usually that doesn't turn out well for
anybody involved let alone me I can't
help it give her the Sun here shouldn't
just give that away to anybody but okay
warm I've almost forgotten it's so warm
that's good right the vine should be
gone now I'm not afraid anymore I just
meet someone to watch them die it's the
Sun we're leaving it with her for now oh
well but now it's dark oh my god is this
what the people of this world lived with
without the Sun here oh okay I don't
feel a hundred percent comfortable with
this but you know what can you do
I guess the vines are gone now so that's
good I mean that other one's still
blocked by a block and I can't I can't
possibly fathom a way to get around that
the vines were seated do you know what
happened I found this plant person she
was barely holding on I gave her the Sun
for now but she said it was too late for
her I understand she was a menace to the
society and you gave her our only way of
survival I need to report this to the
city I still feel like I may have done a
goof there but we'll see oh where am I
now we're about now
am i goat okay goat ah I'm scared to go
oh okay thank you
are you the kid I'm looking for why
where you have me right
hey a year to trade three yeah anything
you want to get rid of make me an offer
I'll give you something in return we
have something like that markiplier I
got a tube water I've got a cube how
about this glass tube full of water I
got from a robot it's very special been
blessed by a god I talk to you inside my
head you like glass do I do you
I love glass so much so much I have too
much glass and not enough other things
got to get rid of my old bottles and
vials to make a run produce go that's
why I set up a trade post in the first
place
sorry guys handsome no girl huh well I
don't want to give away the I don't want
to give away the amber I don't know if I
want to give away the strange journal
but soul it's like God I guess weight
trade this don't you want to find out
what it says first what's out of hook
out here if I want to take books I can't
read okay nevermind then I really don't
want to give away the amber now is
silver special locket it's important to
her what I mean maybe I have no other
choice I don't know
I don't think it's right to trade this
way I was thinking the same thing you
have on those coin things I've dug up a
couple of these before
Oh guy who trade me for the best things
for him like one time he brought me this
little machine that plays music I don't
know what's call but you have to wind it
up
that's called a Walkman that's called an
iPod
Brickel that's it I wish the guy would
come back soon I haven't seen him in
forever I want to do more trades with
him alright so I got nothing to trade
how about I just step on all your [ __ ]
well that's a lot of shiny things it's a
lot of glass wool rusty bucket scrap
metal shells and rocks saw this for by
the way I don't think they're neat okay
you live your life the way you want to
live okay all right bye screaming go
yeah
all right see you later I feel like we
bonded on an emotional level there
there's any spirit animal Minds probably
goat screaming in the wind I've got a
cloak or shawl looks like an altar put
this on here nope okay goodbye
alright then maybe I should looked at
all the things in this weird Museum I
may be an orb
material looks like amber ah okay wait
reminds me of the one the robot from The
Barrens is holding which one was that
I don't remember what that is at all
this whole place is weird because it's
just got these big like stone obelisks
like what are they oh hello what are you
in for the flood can take away our
farmlands but it can't take away our
fish oh that's the optimistic spirit you
keep doing what you do and how the head
did I get over here alright I'll be back
I guess
looks like herrings anchovies sardines I
have no clue well as god markiplier
would say best not to ponder the the
mysteries of fish just carry on with
your adventure ah let's stop by any goat
you seen yell at them profusely good Oh
more oh God huh what's with that goat
alright
oh [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah I can do
that too I'm a god you know God mad all
right yeah that's a normal girl would
you like to help me hurt my Ron's
there's a great reward in some of you I
promise
ah earth excellent to the south of the
peninsula inhabited by my rims they are
all standing in unfortunate spots you
need to move them on the girder come on
if you get stuck ring a bell and they'll
all return to their original positions
good luck okay so it's a the puzzles are
that they're sad go right there I know I
know right oh man all these goats are
depressed
hey that goats excitable all right then
you carry on with your life I suppose
okay so all these ones are standing in
unfortunate spots unfortunate oh so sad
oh but if I move them ah maybe it's like
all this I can't do anything now welp
I've done goofed it a whole bunch
already let's see if I can do this not
stupid like I know my way around this
one think about this real close and
definitely I'm not stalling for time i
thinkI thunk I got egg actually I think
I was right pretty sure that Barbara
Police are not the demon ones all right
ah okay here we go got it
how's easy little bit all right then I'm
gonna believe that's normal
your gods are weird he provided a great
service for all Ram kind in the ten it
is fine Ram wool oh thank you I feel
better about this arrangement
you're a good trader I say traitor right
then how you doing ramming this Ram is
chewing on a ball of moss now I'm
curious what do you think they taste
like markiplier moss not the RAM hey the
RAM and the moss say you can hardly tell
them apart when you're a god such as me
far beyond evolved the need for food the
light from these lanterns will have to
do for now I'm starting to see some very
small sprouts we'll probably take some
time for these to bear fruit Oh your bet
you wouldn't like me stomping all over
them small sprouts I gotta be careful I
don't step on these Oh
what oh sorry my godly feet have just
crushed your crops that's what God's do
you take care now so I destroy all your
hopes and dreams after I suppose all
right so where am I going here Bing bong
hello anybody in this Shack I can't even
go in this check guess I can't go any
checks so these these must be the town
of hurtings but I do note that that wall
is probably what I need to trade with
the person so I got I went in a big-ass
circle this is the beginning how did I
get back here I don't know how this all
looped around but I guess it did alright
then most of the green moss covering our
villages already lost its glow if it
wasn't for the thin strip left on the
boundaries of the land people could
easily fall into the ocean now light
land and water becomes indistinguishable
here well that's no good why is the
water all puke-green
what's going on with your weird town
whoo your eyes glow in the dark yeah
just like the Sun the Sun that I left
with the vine lady land is fragmenting
in an alarming rate I don't like to
think about the day when this town
finally loses to be intruding see I'll
have to find another place to settle Oh
boohoo I didn't know you're going here
slowly being chipped away already but I
still trying to stay alive I think
doesn't matter one day the world will
finally give up this fight I just hope
I'm not allowed to see it I'm bringing
back the Sun though that won't fix the
root of the problem just like the other
lady said but don't lose heart without
the Sun the world would die much faster
at the very least I'm sure everyone
would like to see the Sun again God what
happened
I guess people eat the moss everything
eats the moss the goats eat the moss
what happened in this place
like why is this place so decrepit last
week I saw more of those squares while I
fishing and you better than to get close
though
squares squares man they're bad news hey
come on
tiny marks tim is a square you take that
back you take that back
a what sorry I'm just so scared but what
it's up you're gonna get dizzy if keep
spinning around like that I'll get our
huh grandpa says the tower used to spin
all the time bringing sunlight to the
world want to see it too well I'm here
now I guess it'll only be a matter of
time again man bees not Moss well that's
good
ah sorry I keep getting startled
whenever I go in there well that that's
super weird though everyone seems to be
like pessimistic about the state of the
world why why is it everything in this
world just dying and there's no recovery
I'm not ready yet but would you like
some stew I'm not hungry but thank you
it's at least I can offer the Savior hey
I don't know how you know that I don't
have the Sun do you talk to a God inside
your head no I don't think so that's
just me so why don't you let me do the
the prophesizing and me hide my identity
for at least one time
hello the crops have been growing poorly
without the Sun and there's no telling
how long our surpluses will last please
save her you have to hurry
I I'll do my best I kind of left the Sun
you know the very important thing that
everybody trusts to fix everything here
except the ones that are super
pessimistic you know I kind of left in a
trusted it's weird
buying lady yeah your trade hell yeah I
am you want you want trade oh I got you
some trade how about some wool I'm
something
it's like wall right what can this will
get me wool huh that'll get you this
fine vial of I'm not sure what this is
actually some sort of fabric dye how
about it
yeah sure I can get more wool the plenty
of goats school rode down there to the
snow so I could cheer up three dinner
pleasure doing business all right thank
you I've got a vial of something here
used to dye wool well damn it I just got
rid of my wall all right there's one
more there was one more vine area we put
what is all that is that more building
oh that's weird
oh I see that goes down to the vine lady
but there was one more of these vines
off doors that I can go into now that
it's all free with this one might have
been this one I don't know this doesn't
seem right can't remember where exactly
I went to II what is this ah I know what
to do with it that is the opposite of
correct that I was doing there I know
what to do with this
dammit I got you oh how am I gonna get
the one in the center I don't know about
here I go now
bang woo this squares have got a hello
I'm looking for you
you saved me uh my desktop just frickin
changed on me thank for that
thank you weirdo
you saved me thank you I was trapped in
there for so long
are you a Jew yah you knew my name
Wow the Messiah really does know
everything hey I don't take credit for
nothing about me that I was knowing
about
actually it's me
your brother earlier all right gosh
calamus must be so worried can you bring
me to him I think if you listen on the
wind you'll hear the soft subtle sounds
of Loula
where you had enough come out for dinner
it's a nice moss to cooking all right
Loula you run off or I'll never mind
I'll talk to you wait a minute how did
you know that I was the Messiah I don't
have the son with me your eyes huh they
reminded me of the Sun oh that's why
you're our Messiah right yeah let's go
to our and ignore the voices in my head
that keeps talking to him itself so it's
kind of like a multi-layer psychosis
going on here
well I a lot of people back in my home
world have eyes like mine home world
yeah I'm actually from another world you
see that's not to start ripping
interdimensional holes in the mind of a
child the place where the Sun is in the
sky and not in a tower do you like this
world too I that's nice it's a little
Garbo right now but it's nice hey Talan
let's keep saying out this world is
getting more dangerous by the minute
that's okay you're here now you can make
everything better even though I was
trapped behind a blocky wall from Hell
yeah okay I guess you're following me
now that that's cool what you doing just
in a room just a weird room that doesn't
make a lot of sense why were you there
anyway good thing I know how to draw
boob dicks because that's the crux of my
entire issue here but now I think that
was the other vine door so I should be
able to go back down to the vine lady
and then maybe get the Sun back
hopefully I don't know if that's a
guaranteed thing maybe I don't know what
I'm afraid she's gonna betray me but
also I'm afraid I'm going to go down
there and she's gonna be dead
I don't know I forgot my glowing eyes
hello i the son leaving it with here for
now I'm not afraid anymore thank you
alula are you okay she just looked away
oh it's so sad that's so sad why it's so
sad they just introduced a character and
of course I get suspicious because
that's what I always do in games with
the introduce a character and then like
she's dying in a way that's kind of
reflection of this whole world you're
introduced to this world right away and
and it's dying the whole world is not
the people in it they're dying some of
them even know it and in a way there's
like a mini reflection of that fate that
fate that the people of this world may
have to accept if this if this thing
doesn't fix everything like I don't know
it's just like could it actually fix
everything or is this just it's just a
band-aid they keep saying that there's a
deeper there's a deeper problem in this
world
what's the deeper problem why is this
world dying besides the fact that it
relies on the Sun what's going on here
it's amazing that they're able to do
that though just like introduce a
character to me just like that and then
Olson uh-huh sorry I think I think that
it was actually up here the brother
listening I just need to follow the
sounds of a Luna when I come home but
Louie where are you how the hell did I
get over there then what's going on here
going on here
hey come on where we going it was those
you go those way alright we're going
back there oh I hear it's getting louder
oh yeah there it is galavis I do that
you're okay thank goodness I'm here to
help man
it helped assign all that stuff trapped
inside this room and it was really scary
but then the Messiah saved me trapped in
the ruins you'll be trapped in our home
you're never leaving again yeah there
was a weird stuff in the door you know
the floating squares we see next to the
ocean sometimes the stuff you told me to
stay away from what it's pretty illusion
out this isn't good
don't worry I didn't touch it oh I'm not
hurt or anything bone still if it gets
any worse we might have to find
somewhere else to live what if this
square stuff exactly bad anything that
touches them just sort of gets messed up
whenever you hear people saying the
world is decaying that's what they meant
obviously you should avoid them too I
will okay I will anyway can't thank you
enough for rescuing my sister Savior
just call me Niko
oh gosh would you not be rude to call
you by name huh
why would it be I mean I'm just a kid
like you guys uh-huh then would you like
to visit our house Niko bigger I don't
think is a good idea you can't be
spending time and random houses all
right sure hey let's go
alrighty then I'm not controlling so I'm
just going on an adventure
you live in the ruins oh shoot looks
like we can't get passes block seriously
Wow I'll be up bad okay all right that's
great I literally never thought it I
thought of that actually no I thought of
reasoning with the box as if it was a
living object anyway that's what I do
you get used to all kinda debris after
living here for a while in my Batcave
come on our house isn't far from here or
should I call my bird cave I'm the bird
man all right then where are you taking
me stranger where are we going ah
welcome to our home I know it's not much
but people need to make yourself
comfortable
I dropped the voice man I'm in here oh
there it is oh not you kid she just
comes around the corner all grafters
yeah I got the good stuff here we want
you to have this something I can trade
are secure thank you i-i'm so nice
oh feathered the edges are glowing
yellow it's sacred feather from the
great prophet oh yeah she's this old
lady our daddies - no her feathers can
glow in the dark and she can see into
the future she's cool
does she also talk to a god named
markiplier in her head I don't think so
what something like that
forget I said anything yeah she gave me
wonderful president father before she
died a good father wanted to pass this
down as an heirloom Levu if he was more
fitting for you to have it are you sure
totally sure yeah I think that's what
father would have wanted it thank you
are you so sweet so nice oh you have a
bed that I could take a nap in the bed
more like a mattress it's a bad more
like a mattress it's a bad more like a
mattress back room is full of dust and
cobwebs you like to fish neato
yeah so do we they're good in suits for
soups but I know some people back home
would like to eat them raw yeah yep
all raw fish sushi is pretty good look
clover symbol on the cover of this book
he's just like oh my book gosh I still
need to finish studying it
oh I framed gave it to me for solstice
day he's the one who wrote it actually
he's also the one who taught me how to
read this guy's everything to me really
oh I have a few more of his books
somewhere hey speaking of books I've got
this stranger oh by the way what
happened to the Sun I lent it to someone
in the ruins she said she wanted to feel
the Sun again before she oh you must be
talking about Mays done her name she's a
powerful plant spirit
she used to protect the Glen once the
Sun died your health rapidly
deteriorated oh I'm glad you were able
to find her in time I think we might be
already too late to save her oh no no
it's not the voice no but I'm glad she
got to see the Sun again
oh that's sad of the twin gym sprint
success there's being um nerdy like so
anyway that's all the time I got for
this one thank you everybody so much for
watching I hate to shut the world down
on Nico I always feel bad when I do that
but a lot of time for now so thanks
again everybody for watching hope you're
enjoying it let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]